hi there steve kaufman and today
i want to talk to you about
noticing
i'm going to talk about noticing for two
reasons first of all because i was doing
some noticing
while uh working with our mini stories
in spanish actually and i was filming it
on movavi and i was going to show you
how i would approach spanish as a
newcomer to the language
unfortunately the movavi started hanging
up on my computer i couldn't get the
whirring beach ball to stop so i was
unable to do that
but it made me think
that that
noticing is you know when i talk of the
three keys a positive attitude towards
the language towards learning and so
forth attitude time that you spend
enough time an hour a day i would
recommend but the third the noticing is
often people have trouble understanding
what that is all about and that's what i
wanted to show you
and
to me acquiring vocabulary words and
phrases is not so much a matter of
memorizing as it is a matter of noticing
and the same is true of grammar you have
to start noticing it you can only learn
what you notice if you don't notice it
if you don't see it you can't learn it
and if you notice it and continue to
notice it and notice it say a word or a
phrase or a structure in different
contexts eventually it's going to click
in
so and when we talk about grammar first
of all phrases and this came up in a
tweet
tweeted out by someone that i follow
who's an english teacher and he says the
lexus and that's not the japanese car
that's
l-e-x-i-s which is words and phrases the
vocabulary column embodies all of the
grammar
and the basic unit there is the phrase
which i'm going to explain to you a
little more
later on and i'm going to continue to
sort of beat this theme
but but grammar in its essence is
actually very easy
to understand and very often we pick up
a book a language book a grammar book
and we're hit with all kinds of rules
and explanations and gerunds and
predicates and intransitive and i don't
know what
and it's intimidating
but it needn't be
because essentially all we're dealing
with in any language it's the same for
every language you're dealing with verbs
and nouns you're dealing with actions
and things are people
and everything hinges around these two
objects
so in the case of verbs
in some languages the verbs may change
for gender you know whether it's a he or
she doing it it may change for number it
may change for person and in some
languages the verb doesn't change but
there are other words telling us what's
going on very often as in spanish if the
verb changes for a person we may not get
the person in the phrase because it's
obvious from the form of the verb
you know time or tenses in some
languages there's a very sort of
[Applause]
complex you know changes take place in
the form of the verb to reflect that
time in other languages like chinese
you'll just get a time word yesterday
tomorrow
often
just now while
we get those as well in say english
but the verbs also change to some extent
they don't change as much for a person
in english as they do in other languages
but all of that doesn't matter we get
used to those things the basic principle
is we have verbs and
in all languages we have adverbs that
describe the verbs and that's the verb
and then we have nouns
and the nouns in some languages have
gender
uh number like
one or many is dealt different dealt
with differently in different languages
but it's always there the issue of how
many
and there are adjectives
so you got the verbs and the nouns noun
includes pronoun
pronoun could be
he it could be witch anything that
stands for
the noun okay so you got the verbs and
the nouns and then you got a way of
connecting verbs to nouns
which in english and in many western
european languages is a preposition
so i go to the store
in slavic languages you may get a
preposition but you may also get a
changing in the form of the noun which
we call case endings but that's still
you know i write with a pen
and so the with the pen forces the pen
the word for pen changes that's a case
ending but it's still these connections
between the verb and the noun in
japanese the preposition actually comes
after
so instead of being to the store it's
store two but the same principle you've
got to connect these verbs to the nouns
and that's all there is
and so um when you have uh
phrases which are the key
you know element that i you got to start
noticing what's happening in this phrase
the phrase might just be
a connecting word with a noun
or it might be a verb a connecting word
and a noun
and when i read languages i say what i
think is worthwhile saving what i think
helps me notice the language there's no
hard and fast rule you can say the whole
sentence or you can say short phrases
and i'm going to give you an example of
that from our many stories and i think
the many stories are a great place to do
this noticing because
if you have long sentences with many
many phrases it's more difficult to
notice these phrases as i'll demonstrate
in the many stories the sentences are
very short typically two maybe three
sometimes one phrase in the sentence but
first of all let me tell you that in so
far as the many stories are concerned
we're a little bit behind we're relying
on our volunteers
but we have
60 stories in english basically or 50
let's say in english 50 in greek
we have 20 in russian 10 in arabic 10 in
swedish 10 in german five in italian
come along
we have 20 in european spanish 20 in
korean
we have 15 in french we have five in
esperanto
we have 15 in dutch 10 in chinese 10 in
polish 20 or no we have 50 in select
but we have a bunch more that are almost
there belarusian we have 10 danish farsi
finnish hebrew
polish
japanese are working on ukrainian we're
working on portuguese romanian we're
working on thai turkish and we've got
people saying they're going to help us
on mongolia indonesia and bulgarian
croatian urdu malayalam cantonese tatar
hungarian latvian three different
versions of arabic we'll see how far we
get with these however
and they will be loaded up gradually
into link and those that are not
languages that link will figure out some
way that we make them accessible in any
case anything that is that link any of
our content is always available for free
download audio and text it's only when
you start to use our functionality that
you have to pay
now
as an example let's say in spanish what
do i really mean by noticing a phrase so
in the first story here which is a story
of miguel who is a cook
it says miguel celebanta miguel
miguel levanta now i could look up the
word levanta it'll tell me that that
means rise up
say is himself herself himself
miguel gets up i can also look up the
phrase miguel celebanta save the phrase
miguel
allah says allah says i look up says
it's 6.
okay last says it'll tell me it's 6
o'clock because it says ores allah says
at that's the preposition allah says
allah says at six o'clock good phrase i
say the phrase
and the next one is todas las mananas
all the mornings every morning i look up
mananas it's mornings last tells me it's
the okay the morning
i also start to notice that in spanish
the las has to agree with mananas las
mananas and so does todas todas las
mananas they all have to agree
okay i say todas las mananas
the next one starts preparing
prepara first of all very similar to
english prepara miguel has disappeared
we start to notice in spanish we don't
need to have who's doing it just prepare
breakfast
preparation and of course using linky
just look at this so you know l oh
masculine though is el elves you know
and then it says
cafe so once again cafe we know
okay that's like ah we look it up
again we have a se
i thoma i take for myself a coffee
so i say that setoma cafe
now as i'm saving these phrases
i'm
accumulating
words and phrases that i can review i
can review in flashcards i can review in
reverse flashcards from the english i
can review in multiple choice in
different ways
and
if i say to myself boy you know that's a
little confusing it's reflexive
i'll say that and maybe tag it as
reflexive now
obviously some of these things
you don't know that it's reflexive your
first time at it you're told what the
meaning is in fact there's a for all of
the many stories there's a translation
so you can see what the meaning is but
it may not
you may not notice the fact that this is
a pattern here that it's a reflexive
pattern it doesn't matter because when
you're noticing things you only notice
some things a lot of things initially
most things just pass you by but you can
go back again later on and look again
and notice some more things and every
time you would review this story you'll
notice more so noticing is not something
that you're going to do one lesson and
notice everything and learn everything
that's not how it works you're going to
go there you'll notice certain things
certain things are going to click in you
go away first of all all the vocabulary
in the mini story repeats three times
and it's uh there are questions which
have both negative and positive in them
so you're starting to pick up on the
positive and the negative and you can
listen to that little three-part
ministry five ten times if you want
and each time you'll notice or you may
not but every third or fourth time
you'll notice something and you may go
back in and you may save some different
phrases and notice but the process is
one of noticing and the core unit in my
opinion is not
the sentence
uh
obviously you need the words but to
embody
the structure of the language it's the
phrase and so you should get in the
habit of noticing phrases and if
possible tagging them if you're using
link and that's why the mini stories
here with their relatively short
sentences are a great place to do that
so i realized it took quite a long time
here today i hope that's of interest and
if you enjoy these podcasts please
subscribe
[Music]
you